hello belief nation we're going to
continue the experiment of my favorite
top ten rose to success basically all
the videos that we've had from the past
month the top tens
pulling out what my favorite rule was
and mashing them together just for you
let me know what you think and as always
if you hear something that really
resonates with you please leave it in
the comments below put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
when I gave
London just before Christmas the soaring
melodies the thumping beat of the music
and the quirky charisma of lead singer
Chris Martin had the crowd on its feet
we rely more on enthusiasm than actual
skill whatever you do do it do you ask
people like it more
I can't does like I sure I can't sing
like Beyonce I can't write songs they
helping John
but we can do the best we can with what
we've got
so that's what we did we just go for it
but I really get motivated when people
tell me it'll never happen it's like you
know this I mean it happens to me all
the time in my business you got
understand guys I got to reinvent myself
every record that means every three to
six months I got to find myself again
because the last record or the new
record is not as big as the last record
she ain't pretty
I mean well I made my point I got a guy
that's sitting in an office there hasn't
been to a club salad you and quanto sign
you know antenna located food I'd say oh
I lied no good I don't understand
nothing telling me what a hit record is
stick to your gut stick to what you
believe in understand your Worth and go
okay well this is where you build an
infrastructure at least in my business
we built our own team I own one one-stop
shop where if someone says no we don't
think it is they don't worry we'll check
back in in a month and we'll see who you
know and we just happen ago Oh that'll
never work and in in a month at deep
organization you know this is really
starting to sound like a hit yeah so
that motivates me that that to me is
what makes me get up in the morning go
what's next what were you like as a
child
um I I was a combination of reclusive
and obsessed with what I wanted to do
when I was two I wanna I was sitting in
front of the TV drawing Fred
Flintstone's and woody woodpecker's and
at age seven I'm running around like a
crazy person doing voices but at the
same time I would try to make animated
films and try to figure out exactly how
that art form worked when did you do
your first cartoon how old were you and
what was it I was in seventh grade it
was called space pirates it was terrible
high as you know I was a bouncer for
many years I remember coming home one
night after a big fight run up to the
kitchen they get ice and I'm my hands
swollen and then just another day at
work and I was feeling like just bummed
about the fact that I was still doing
this job after all this time
and at that one moment I was like why
are people what wasn't what's up why do
people have so much anger why do I have
to you know why is this my daily life to
suppress everybody's anger or check
everybody's anger that comes into the
giant 3,000 person nightclub mm-hmm
and my father it was so simple but my
father said you know then I've traveled
around the world I've been to India I've
been to Russia I've been to China I've
been all up in the south and all through
South America and I've realized
something I said what he said people by
and large are good people
sounded pretty simple and yet it meant
so much and if you look at my facebook
page if you look at the way that all
that positive energy I don't think
there's a page in the world in history
that harbours is much positive energy as
one would see on this Facebook page and
it's when you put out to and it's really
that right and I say that because I say
that because if you believe that in your
heart and not everybody watching this
can say that or is ready to say that or
it's comfortable with themselves enough
to say that but if you really believe in
your heart that people by and large are
good people it affects the way that you
address the world as you see post in and
post our I I address a world that in my
soul I feel is comprised of good people
yeah I've always been driven you know
even a young age all I ever wanted to do
was become a footballer or a soccer star
and that was my only ambition you know I
know it's different these days with kids
you know there's obviously this Fame
this fortune and it might be easy for me
to say that because obviously I've done
I've done very well out of the game but
you know I'd still be playing this game
even if I wasn't being paid for it not
know that I don't want to be paid for it
I still would be playing for paying
playing this this sport the notion that
we are not enough is a lie and I think
more young people need to know that that
like when you have that thought that
you're not enough that that's based on a
lie that somebody said to you or so or a
lie that somebody did to you like
somebody said or did something to you to
make you feel like you're not enough
and that's not true that you are
everything that you need to be that you
have everything that you need to have to
be the person that you're meant to be
and to be the best version of who you're
meant to be it may mean that you have to
work really hard and it may mean that
you have to ask for help but you are
perfectly blessed you know you are
exactly who you're supposed to be to be
joyful in this life so don't be afraid
to work hard and don't be afraid to ask
for help so you can get there because
that's your truth you have to be
authentic I mean you've got no hope if
you try to pretend to be Reed Hastings
or Mark Zuckerberg or Bill Gates or
whoever you want to think your CEOs are
that you've met you know that is crazy
and you got to really get comfortable
with yourself your strengths and
weaknesses people are inspired by
authenticity and I'm just surprised how
many people feel like they're acting and
or try to act and you may be a really
quiet person and that's fine but if you
have that fierce will that desire for
the institution the company to be great
and your own role and that is secondary
and you authentically Express that
whatever ways you do then you'll be
greatly accepted okay and so that's all
it takes is to be authentic and not try
to be something else and to
fundamentally care at your core about
what's good for the company and if
everybody knows and you act in the
notion of what's good as best as your
judgement can tell what's good for the
company they will see that and people
will follow you and they won't be
cynical it's when you hide things it's
when you pretend everybody has their own
kind of sense of accomplishment what
unisom opening weekend box office for
winning Academy Awards to me it is being
in an audience anonymously and watching
people watch my movies and seeing how
we're entertaining people the first true
experience I ever had of that was about
five days after Toy Story
took four years for me to make Toy Story
all of us at Pixar and I was with flying
with my family we were changing planes
in the dallas-fort Worth Airport I got
off the plane and there was a little boy
about four years old with his mother and
he was holding a woody the cowboy doll
and it's the first time I'd seen one of
my characters outside of Pixar and I was
so stunned my boys dad look look the
look on his face he couldn't wait to
show his father who was getting off the
plane his toy and I realized at that
moment that that character that I with
the help of everybody Pixar created over
four years no longer belonged to me it
belonged to him and I to be honest it's
so it's so much in my memory they look
on that little boy's face I think about
that little boy every single day working
at Pixar and that's why we do what we do
well certainly every product we do is
absolutely as capable as it can possibly
be you know there's nothing there's no
holding back we are the people at
Microsoft come into work every day
building the best products they can and
they're very proud you know you go out
go into schools and see how kids are
using this stuff going ask people about
how their jobs have changed because of
the personal computer you know we're
sitting there listening to our customers
saying how they'd like to make things
better so we're we do absolutely our
best job and in fact that's why we've
been successful you know anybody who
holds back in this business isn't gonna
be around for long because this is a
business where you always have to be
moving at a very rapid pace
ask yourself what if no one ever bought
any of my work what if I'm never gonna
sell a book or publish a book or a short
story are you gonna continue to write
and if the answer is yes because I have
to do then yeah then you are a writer
and whether you're selling out I can't
know but if their stories and you that
have to get out and want to put them
paper with whether you ever get the
affirmation of a contract or a book in
your hand or being on the bestseller
list if you still have to tell your
stories then then your writer if you can
give it up then then it probably would
be an act of sanity to learn accounting
or something like that in the long
history of the world only a few
generations have been granted the role
of defending freedom in its hour of
maximum danger
I do not shrink from this responsibility
I welcome it
I do not believe that any of us would
exchange places with any other people or
any other generation the energy the
faith the devotion which we bring to
this endeavor will light our country and
all who serve it and the glow from that
fire can truly light the world and so my
fellow Americans ask not what your
country can do for you ask what you can
do for your country
my fellow citizens of the world ask not
what America will do for you but what
together we can do for the freedom of
man finally whether you are citizens of
America or citizens of the world ask of
us here the same high standards of
strength and sacrifice which we ask of
you with a good conscience are only sure
reward with history the final judge of
our deeds let us go forth to lead the
land we love asking his blessing and his
help but knowing that here on earth
God's work must truly be our own I see
myself as a pioneer in the game
I see Drake as a pioneer and again
people like little Wayne and there's
only sort of people who who really come
and define their generation
other than being a part of their
generation and it's cool to be a part of
it as well but this I see myself as a
leader and somebody who changes things
and doesn't just follow so you've sort
of arrived at these different approaches
to writing what was the first to your
mind like the first writing piece that
you did to kind of put you on the map
we're not like I've arrived but you're
like okay I actually I actually could
make this work I could actually really
be good at this or wow I get I just got
recognition for this piece I mean was
were there any sort of defining moments
and you're in your career as a writer
yeah I think I mean I don't know I'm not
yeah the middle things that I remember I
remember like I was like but by the way
the best way to get about it get started
anything is to be willing to work for
free yeah internships like to me are the
path to anything and I mean I really
think being there's definitely a lot of
people who are entitled basically they
have so much to say but anyway yeah if
you want to you can want to live in your
passion whatever your passion is
you have to be willing to not make money
at it you want to do what you love you
got to do you have to you people you
have a choice you can choose money or
you can choose what you love that Joseph
Campbell has a great quote that I always
use I don't know if you guys know this
the just beautiful
so the here what the thousand fish yeah
the great kind of professor of mythology
but he said the the insecure if you guys
heard this the insecure way is the
secure way you guys have heard that
quote and what it means basically is you
know my parents and I'm sure like most
people's parents say get a good job
trying to make some money make a good
living yeah and because I think that's
secure if you make go and make money but
if you do a job you make money lose that
job yeah then you lose the money you
have nothing right right where he says
if you choose your passion yeah actually
isn't matter when you make money to lose
money because you're always gonna have
your passion be happy so it doesn't
actually matter or not your safety net
right and and but the challenge of that
is that it might be eight years or four
years before you're actually making a
living at it yeah versus versus
something else what about the the the
the business of being what you are now
they had the musician the songwriter I
mean did you did you display an early
talent for for singing awful I didn't
actually I got thrown out of the choir
video I was thrown out of the choir for
I think as far as I know it was for
talking and and I always remember my dad
used to say to me you know because I
used to say dad that when I was like you
know 16 17 18 and my dad was threatened
to throw me out of the house if I didn't
get job within a certain amount of time
so obviously I went out and got jobs but
I was saying I want to be a singer you
know I think I'm gonna be rich and
famous and he would say you know
everybody wants to be a pop saying
everybody was I said and I would say no
dad everybody wants to be a pop singer
when they're 12 you know when they're 12
I'll this is my whole life this is what
I want to do but um but but I've lost my
train of thought
reason famous your ambition I mean was
that I think I had two very very strong
ambitions and they've always fought
against one another always and one was a
passion for music and an ability to
communicate through music and really a
sense of purpose through music and two
was this desire to be an enriched and
famous is not right because actually
rich never came into it I actually
realized about six months ago someone
put a question to me and actually
realized that at no point during my
early life when I was in on all my
ambitions or even when III started to to
realize my ambitions at no point did I
ever occur to me though one of the
byproducts of this would be that I could
buy whatever I wanted or you know live
in a big house have a flashy car all the
things that are very pleasant you know
but it really hadn't occurred to me had
never occurred to me so I didn't want to
be rich I wanted to just want it to be
filthily famous there's a lot of work
that's real responsible for that's other
people can't do you know there's a
saying that says you can lead a horse to
the water but you can't make them drink
in the presence of common sense and
rational thinking we went even in the
throws of your despair it is your
responsibility if you are willing to
still commit to saving your own life to
hear that and just walk towards that
voice you know so you know I want to
work I want to recognize personal
responsibility you know and in what we
try to do here today one of the things
that make you know body building a
significant vehicle for therapy and
maybe even a tool you know towards
personal development is just that you
know in order to be able to do this
effectively you have to recognize your
personal responsibility so with that
said you know I'm going to submit to you
that the word believe believe his work
you can substitute work or believe you
know because when I'm working what are
you working for if you're working
without a belief in the idea that you
gonna get paid
what does your works for what is the
purpose so I believe that you know to
talk about believing is to talk about
being willing to do the work for reason
you know don't be a fool to sit back and
do it cuz somebody else doing it because
the one thing you gonna do is following
somebody else's footsteps it just gonna
be a shadow who will be a shadow for the
rest of their life and I'll say if you
got a little sublet you know how to do
progress that it keeps my Luther King
tried to commit suicide twice you guys
he don't sign here
JFK went through periods of deep illness
deeply deeply ill where people thought
he would die these types of things right
Winston Churchill went through deep deep
depressions so you can become one of
those people doesn't mean you can become
one of them because that's I mean those
guys are in their own universe but you
know you can become somebody of great
power if you've gone through that
because you've been hardened do you guys
see what I mean here if you've been
through that kind of [ __ ] then if
you've conditioned yourself to pull
yourself out of something like that if
the world gets offered up you while all
the other people they're used to
happiness they're like whoa happy
they're like my happy world's falling
apart my happy world it's falling apart
gets off double your sight it's all good
baby yeah
you don't care because you're adjusted
to it so you're a jet you have taken
conscious control do you guys see it I
mean okay so there's benefits being a
hard case newbie means that you can be
better than any of the guys that had it
easily it'll be harder to get but you
can excel to a higher level than all the
people that were naturally good if you
choose to but for you it will be a life
of commitment in the same way that a guy
that wants to get kind of big in the gym
if he's gonna be big in the gym and he's
a hardgainer a little skinny dude he's
gonna have a higher commitment level to
get to that level you're gonna have a
higher command level you're not gonna
get to average as easily and sometimes
even striving to state average won't
work for you because you slip back so
you have to you have to really commit
you have to you have to take your foot
off the parking brake man you have to
you have to burn the boats as they say
and just go for it as a hardcase new me
if you do that you can slowly build
those willpower muscles
slowly react lament your body to
positivity build up friends build up
abundance build an amazing situation for
some of you amazing amazing things I
continually learn from my mistakes and
other people's mistakes see
entrepreneurs think that hey to create
that billion dollar company 100 million
dollar company or even a million our
company had to be really smart and sure
brains is part of it luck is a huge
component but what I've learned over the
years is everyone no matter how smart
you are you're gonna fail many times
you're gonna make mistakes just look at
Mark Zuckerberg Facebook worked out his
version of snapchat that was a copycat
did not work out right so there's other
areas in which Facebook failed but
Facebook overall as the company has done
great just because you're smart doesn't
mean you're always gonna succeed with
everything you try or touch but every
time you do something you will learn new
things you'll make mistakes and if you
learn from these mistakes and avoid
making them over and over again you'll
actually increase your odds of
succeeding as time goes on and the best
way to do this is not just to learn from
your mistakes but it's also to learn
from the mistakes of others Rockefeller
Carnegie all these people who are
entrepreneurs years ago in the 1800's
1900s they themselves use business
principles and concepts that are still
applicable in today's world sure we have
the internet but the same strategies and
concepts that they use are still
applicable right so learn from their
mistakes learn will work for them what
didn't work then why and bring that into
what you're doing today
the very beginning of me getting into
the industry I would you know be out and
about and I would hear girls or
actresses or musicians or whatever you
know they would say oh no I don't want
to be in a relationship because I don't
want to have to choose between being in
a relationship and having a career and I
thought to myself
oh and I get to know that when I find
that person that's gonna be my you know
life partner I won't ever have to choose
because they'll be accepting of me
completely for who I am not district not
not me being able to just like do
whatever I want necessarily but they
won't be threatened or have weird
motives or what they will be accepting
of me the things I love the ambition
what I aspire to be what I want to
create they'll be accepting and
supportive and then I started to realize
oh my god that's not true that's not
like that fairy tale that I had is not
true for me right now yeah just on this
yeah
[Music]
I'll tell you the truth is that I mean
I'm a romantic and I don't I kind of
believe in this fairy tale I mean and in
some ways I think that's always been to
my advantage because like if you can
believe in something great I feel like
you can achieve something great I have
that same belief system with everything
from went from career to my life my
personal line everything and I will do
everything it takes to not fail and I
did everything it took but it still
failed the bad that comes along with the
good is a journey I learned so much from
that journey I mean you were
unforgivingly
who you are have you always been like
that no what what happens like when I
was in college do you like like were you
ever insecure I still am insecure like
that I mean there's probably people
snickering backstage right now that
questions like I when I was in college I
didn't want to come out as a progressive
because I would eliminate like half of
my future employers and in Washington DC
I was like look I gotta look neutral
here so I can get a job someday I I
found progressively you know in some of
these lessons were foisted upon me I
mean I mentioned earlier so not to
repeat a story but it's at Google I am
working on this team and this Wireless
stuff
it was incredible my responsibility
Larry had given me Larry Page had given
me billions of dollars to go take on the
wireless carriers and I was in over my
head I I didn't have a background on
this stuff and I was learning fast and I
was pretty good at it
but one day a decision came up and I
didn't know what to do and my work
partner wrote in the notes Chris doesn't
know what to do about this and at Google
the notes are published to the whole
company so I see the notes get published
I'm like what you do you just ruin my
career everyone's gonna know like I'm
smoking mirrors and I thought it was
over for me and then the next meeting
some new engineers who didn't report to
me and Larry
himself showed up with ideas on what to
do is solve this problem and I was like
oh my god I just became more powerful
I now have influence I have more bodies
working for me who don't even report to
me and it was I mean I wish I could say
I was like it was an enlightened choice
I'd made it was totally voiced upon me
and I was angry about it but it worked
and so along the way I realized that the
candor the authenticity the
vulnerability is what actually attracts
the other people to you it's it's the
insecurity roots you in this place of
showing your impervious that you've got
all the answers but what that does is it
renders everyone around you helpless
there's like I'm not valued here right
and so when you start to admit like I
don't know what I'm doing I need some
help then people started tracking you
and working with you I mean I I have a
principle that I guide my life by and I
try and teach us to our entrepreneurs
called bold humility there are all these
business books that say like hey be
humble be humble be humble but humility
is not a natural state for a kick-ass
human being right like if you're here
you probably kick a lot of ass at
something you were probably the best
it's something you're you have ambition
you're a risk-taker you have learned to
hack you are a good talker you have
through the gift of gab wound your way
into an amazing situation you hustle
hustle hustle and I feel like it's
unnatural to apologize for that but
where we get into trouble is when we
feel like we have to extend that to the
[ __ ] we don't know and we have to feel
like we've got it all covered and so I
think I have had such a great like I
don't know if I would have learned this
authenticity if I didn't have Twitter
and the replies being like that means a
lot to me
go for it you know and and that's why I
kind of live a lot of my life in public
as I feel I draw a lot of strength and
reassurance from from the public being
like blick that moment of failure meant
a lot to me and I identify with it tally
for you you've you've got a deal in
Cartoon Network that's Time Warner
you've got a deal with Sony you you've
used this apparatus even the doodle
you're only 23 you've used this existing
system to build up your profile do you
think you could start literally without
any of this support system and create
yourself yeah
course because that's that's how I
started like the way that I got famous
was me going on tumblr and creating my
own website and just putting things out
like that with the strategic you know it
had a strategy to it but putting out
music for free and that's how it got
known and the next thing I know Sony's
like hey we'll give you a bunch of money
to do X oh no we just a little bit and
I've used them to my advantage in the
same way that I've used other things you
know to my event they didn't make it no
not at all you know so I know how to I
know how to do this without you know
those platforms and and another thing is
the fun thing about this is I'm not we
in our squad we're not afraid to fail
like where we're not scared of failing
or whatever so we're learning as we go
so maybe this may be this doesn't work
out but it'll be a learning experience
and that'll help other people look at
the most of the mistakes we made and
figure out what they're trying to do
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of the video did you enjoy
it
are you motivated did you learn
something from it what was your favorite
clip leave it down the comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion I'm
also curious to figure out should this
series continue or not it's one of our
bubble series right now maybe we'll keep
going maybe we won't we'll see so your
comments will make a difference leave it
down and let me know either way if you
hate it that's good too let me know
leave in the comments finally I want to
give a quick shout out to Rebecca
Coleman Rebecca thank you so much for
picking up the eBook version of your one
word I really appreciate you buying it
and also tweeting it out with that
picture I hope you enjoy that glass of
wine as well as you read thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you soon